we haven't started yet your shower right
now
we are live and welcome home strong
sports where winners win and you know
who's winning
thud Dodgers both bad bad big game big
win finally Dave Roberts put together ah
joining me is the the regular crew the
crew is all here we had to do a little
early because uh the big man bill burr
who sold out the forum uh he has to use
the studio so he's more important than
re and re you just got checked bud you
got checked by Bill burr as you smell
your armpit yeah thanks for joining us
our we know you're busy doing Legion
this gang stuff so we appreciate you
coming on our podcast re where you gonna
be
I'll be a Phoenix for uh for uh
storytelling show I'm genuine on
whatever 27 but I will be doing a live
shooter I don't know what that means
that's scary I know it means a jealous
on a par reading it out loud in front of
a crowd real quick if we can get Tebow
out there can he read a role of like
young immigrant made or whatever role
you have John enters oh [ __ ]
Tebow I just got as your agent I just
got you an offer for let's give Sam 120%
of that yeah actually why don't you go
out and read it I'd rather see ya said
you want a role and as your agent I got
you a father as my agents agent I just
double got you a role how about a thank
you for watching us mother Fagin life
thank you thank you thank you so are
you're gonna be at your do you do
nothing but festivals now do you even do
clubs you went past theaters okay so if
there's a festival around you re will be
there pumpkin festival Mormon date dance
night festival I will be there alright
will you be at the festival of festivals
at festival town in festival festival
state USA
Deauville town at Festivus yeah hey
Jason where are you gonna be nowhere
Jason's gonna be nowhere no I'll be at
the dojo Saturday for our big UFC fight
companion you're gonna be there right
are you not there you won't come and
watch a fight
I don't like Conor McGregor I don't
condone his behavior so it is the you go
I'll be a sales comedy hole Friday night
doing some party thing I don't even know
what it is but feel free to come out the
lineup is really good me and Edwards
Eleanor Kerrigan it's a lot of people
that have fun on it and I haven't seen
Sal forever sales right that's Friday
and then Saturday I'll be at that thing
for our big UFC fight opinion and number
two having after that so come watch the
fights with us be a part of punch-drunk
live and then we're doing the stand-up
after that with Dana said O'Neal you
mean all the lineup is stacked guys
tomorrow night I am at the Brea improv
it's an evening of Sam Triple E and his
weirdo friends I have Mike totally from
the JCL show Kate Quigley the smash
brothers and George Perez and then again
this Saturday night it is a the UFC
viewing party and then a killer lineup
of comics go there the the tickets are
available on Eventbrite just put in
punch-drunk and they will come up only
$10 to watch a night of all your
favorite podcasting friends they'll all
be there and then October 12th I am at
the Philly punch line doing tin foil hat
ah with Eddie Bravo it's uh it's Friday
the 12th at the Philly punch line it's a
10:00 o'clock show and then October 14th
it's the tinfoil hat and I at my my
homeland the 607 is three one five
that's right we're coming to the
Syracuse funny bone in the Destiny mall
named after a stripper CIT Bravo myself
and my mother will be there so you can
meet my mom and ask her what went wrong
oh and I hope to see you at those shows
support the live shows I'm excited
young Christian where's the business is
done so let's talk about who who who's
gonna win the playoffs I think it's
gonna be the Dodgers I feel like we are
the best of the bad you do you know I
think that yeah just what an interesting
both you guys having two games I mean
unless you've the win but you have two
games to get into the plant when one of
the two games and you're in the player
after 164 games 160 260 to dwell on an
oc-3
total but like 164 by the child
it works like you tie your division so
you did win if you win that you're in if
you lose that you still get another
chance and then if you lose that then
you're out and you deserve to be out
what what sucks about it is you know for
somebody who's on the on the wrong side
of that and even a little bit for you to
it's like you burn so many pictures just
to finally get into the actual real real
playoffs you know we're in the wild-card
game whatever but we had to play another
game just to get into the wild-card game
and then by the time we get into that
and in Milwaukee just waiting well
that's kind of what the Cubs did yeah I
mean they didn't put their best foot
forward to win that game they were just
kind of like if we win this we win it if
not well then we got Tuesday we got
Tuesday well you know what dude I think
Ari's got the hardest game dude I mean
that that could easily be an al
championship game I mean I know that the
Red Sox blew everybody out my god they
got [ __ ] Oakland before that
Oakland's yeah so I'm talking about game
against Oakland is a real game dude that
like Oakley's from really set a win team
you talk about the third the fourth best
team in baseball it's just one game
playoff it's like anything goes fine
Andy what's your song know what I know
the Dodgers I don't know any other see
with Colorado it's like [ __ ] that's no
gimme that's a good team they got it in
[ __ ] Chicago though yeah I wouldn't
want to play them you know in [ __ ]
Three Mile Island Stadium ten right too
many too much you know it's great the
Brewers look amazing
I know [ __ ] tell me about it I mean they
look shitty halfway through the year I
ain't afraid when it [ __ ] them up maybe
we were really
what is in your ear her snow buddies
headphones are disgusting I tried to
clean him out with soap and there's just
earwax oh no I'm not I'm not [ __ ]
with that I thought they were your
personal no I just found them over there
the other ones are broken okay I suppose
you account with tinfoil hat on it just
like it just you got tinfoil hat on your
if you saw the way the inside of these
things look you would be doing the same
no I do always have to do that I won't
now Jason the complaint I mom you just
Sam the monitor is a zoo mock my
question is if Erin still cares -
because I saw on Facebook the Cardinals
are out yeah iron doesn't care the one
thing we want talk it doesn't care I
mean I taste books even her I do care I
want that is not zoom is gonna be six to
long as Erin so Kara's always does okay
so that's not Chad that's not not yet
there'll be three three oh yeah Erin
rank the teams five our three Erin rate
and rate the teams of how you would want
them to win and lose like who do you
want to lose you obviously want the Cubs
to lose the most yeah and then yeah yeah
power increase I mean I want the anchors
out you want the Yankees out you want
the Cubs out how much comes out why do
you want the Yankees out cuz you hate
Jews just for you know old times saying
oh you mean anti-semitism mercy on the
Braves right mercy I'll make that shirt
I think are seeing the brace I'm putting
my stock behind Oakland at this point oh
I really listen they got Piscotty I love
that guy Dodgers can't win it I would
like Gokul in the women yeah I mean
nobody hates Oakland nobody hates open
their one of those teams like the
Yankees the Cowboys
I'm like can I tell you I want the
Athletics is because the Raiders play in
the same stadium so in a weird way will
be the Raiders winning at all if you
think about what you really have to
twist yourself and not just have any
success you really really think about it
I would hate
if I were you yeah the deeper they go
the more you have a baseball field in
your on your football stater fit up once
baseball ends what can you do at this
point a disappointment I mean when David
Carr trips on second base that's hey
they do it all the time every kicker
hates kicking like they will go for it
on fourth and one
just because they're like we're gonna
miss his field goal cuz we're kicking
off a [ __ ] in the pitching
multi-billion dollar industry and they
can't get the [ __ ] talking to me like
I said I'm his agent not Mark Davis but
they're ghetto cheap they've always been
like that it's weird they've always it's
always been their problem they're not
willing to spend to win and then it 100
million dollars on a coach that's we
need to make so many t-shirts mercy on
the Braves spend the win I love to see
Cleveland win but man they are the worst
team that's in the area months ago
they're in the shittiest division and
they still only have 88 wins like they
should be scared
they have great players they have great
players are you saying that Bill burr
was wrong when he said that their coach
was the best manager in baseball are you
calling bill burr a liar no no I think
Franco but it's just what everything
what about him makes you do you think it
really wasn't sold out why do you hate
working for Bill burr
hey come on come here Mike our Aaron
real quick what were you talking about
real quick like Mike's in here no use
saying he hates working for Bill burr
anytime he thinks you're a boat he
thinks you're a buffoon why would you
say why would you say Mike's a buffer
that's a great guy yeah I think you
three got gray hair cuts a president of
all the comedy you bastard you guys know
I only say negative things about my wife
Mike looks like he likes to the mirrors
Mike look like he likes to [ __ ] too like
German thrash metal like just really
hard just like straightedge yeah II know
gonna just sweatin that Germans dad's a
legend like I feel like I knows Henry
Rollins like he's really good friends
when Henry Rollins you look like you
were Regan are you vegan my god
my wife is a vegetarian and I resist you
resist it is there a fight over the kid
like who is the kid vegetarian I was
like they have a lot of kids Wow yeah
really
they just were like well they made a
decision do the other two pick on the
vegan kid yeah baby get him my
vegetarian yeah yeah no no it's funny
she she's the cook in the family so she
one day she says she didn't want to eat
what we were having I was eating meat
and she was like my wife said well
there's the only thing I'm cooking
tonight so she went in the kitchen and
started make she whipped up some curry
tofu boom Aaron Aaron what are you
having it's Mike's kids calm down bro
[Laughter]
heart attack Midori stood up me too me
too huh
he almost got us luckily I was on this
other shots well don't worry he's coming
back are you talking about children yeah
oh yeah can he not do that sorry we're
not talking about children and see your
belt so no we don't we don't did you get
a new one Mike we're talking a little
baseball Mike as a Giants fan first of
all thank you for the big house
high-five else yes does that make you
hate the Athletics are you talking about
you like or hate Oakland yeah that's how
people the Sox the White Sox
so would you never come out oh I never
got the guys that wore the hat that was
Giants on one side and and oh I don't
get that at all I fight them you get
killed in Chicago if you did that oh
really by both coaches and White Sox
fans you're literally getting murdered
by both people I don't root for East Bay
teams I don't roof the Raiders you know
it's not about the how about the UM the
Warriors they were East Bay for a while
yeah really
but now that I'm just like well it's
weird like they're moving to the city I
can't not root for us the team but then
you look like a front-runner and it's
like you know well how about the fact
that their new basketball arena looks
like a toilet
have you seen like how it's beside it
looks like a public [ __ ]
I was shocked at how is this young
vegetarian I was shocked at how awful
the Coliseum is yes bad it's garbage
it's one of the worst stadiums I've been
in Oakland duty it was I don't when they
didn't let black people in there I mean
what are we doing here dude it's like
it's from a different time yeah it's
like it's Matt when people were tiny
well what's Oakley gonna have now cuz
they're there Vegas now right yeah well
they don't he says they're definitely
playing there next year that whole thing
that no they're in the LA is still at
the Coliseum next year and Oakland still
in Oakland actually there are some lease
problems where all right don't worry
about he's not saying anything he said
what's a real quick before we move on
tell us about aa ATC's our specials that
there are there new specials yeah so
we're gonna be releasing a special on
Thursday this week for Ted Alexandro
friendly shot at the cellar shot at the
cellar it's it's awesome he's hilarious
he's one of these guys another one of
these guys who's been around for a long
time
and we've we think that he should be a
household name so we're finally seeing a
direct family Mike on what act less like
a nerd Mike I can leave I am NOT the
comic what we say about the reads man
don't [ __ ] the reads up Ari this is a
read for your network your that was a
founding member well you got a huge jock
fan base that way everybody's begging
into your butthole that's what our fans
are you idiot so drop sustain out ed its
atc specialist comm a HD specials comm
check it out it's gonna be available on
Thursday you can pre-order right now is
hilarious but support comics this is the
way to do it you know and like
if you want to be lost in Netflix or you
got only a few people can get on a tree
or whatever so we want to give everybody
another shot at it yeah yeah yeah
Alexandra's a really good comic he's uh
he's a revolutionary comic means it I
mean he goes down in marches on like
Zuccotti Park and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
politically active my hair yeah he
actually does like good bits about it
funny guy check it out alright alright
that's it you do the reads you your G go
check out everybody's door guys shut the
[ __ ] up I think I'm gonna drop my
special breaking it down to you I think
I'm gonna drop zero [ __ ] part two is
gonna be on ATC specials so part one
it's live from the Viper Room there's
gonna be two parts they're about 3540
minutes each for 35 to 40 minutes each
the first one's gonna be zero Fox I
think I'm dropping that round October
21st that's gonna be the day where my
tunes no it's gonna be on VIN ma V V mo
or whatever that is that they'll be out
I mean yeah that vinum vimi vimi vimi l
so that'll be out so it's really good
you should release it on venmo yeah I so
I'm thinking I'm thinking about doing it
dude so um it will be out so that'll be
it live from the Viper Room 1 live from
the Viper Room - because I just people
have such short turns it's means I'm
like why not just break it up and just
so they can watch one and later on drop
the other one a little later and then
they can follow it up and watch the
second part so that's what
yeah that's true dude that's true and
then I I'm excited because I think I
have a half an hour for the next one but
I don't even know if I do an hour on the
next one everyone's just like just do
half an hour's so it's just like why not
just put out half an hour's I think you
have some more in the tank if you gotta
go out and do all that [ __ ] that's my
thing all right I stopped that
conversation you know like thanks for
the support guys no high fives on
anything or I said October 21st Oh
awesome yeah
Sam Wow I'm so happy for you Oh buddy do
you want a hug such a good I'm so proud
of that high-five because we are two of
the whitest guys that we just all right
I play baseball for a long time high
five down speaking of doings absolutely
I could do love did you know the low
five came before the high five hey Ari
I remember this old [ __ ] of like you did
yeah the low five was a minute first
isn't it means are you're not only that
I believe that no it was five I mean
they didn't call it a low fire but it
was low I don't you see Dusty Baker
claims he invented the high five yeah he
did hold on are you telling me in the
history of time yeah the high five
caveman's NeverWet huh I think was that
told that's how that caveman did oh
right says oh yeah his race a shot black
people shocked oh [ __ ] what just have
our sound got cut cuz our sound got
caught because black people run
Hollywood well there were bad people
black people for life
we said that we said we went song night
school where L magical everybody saw it
you know I haven't seen it no I didn't
see it but I will see it Oh what is
happening what is going on this black
people juice let's stop talking about
black people for a second shall we and
maybe we'll have a show you know cycle
like that Ted Alexandro he's not gonna
like that he's probably gonna be a
revolutionary guy that your next [ __ ]
special dude or your next festival
you're performing yeah yeah maybe okay
yeah I'm nari I'm bombing today I got
nobody's jumping on my floor I'm doing
social media I would be laughing up
sorry yeah a bunch of us went to the
Rams
Vikings game at the Coliseum yeah I know
super fun and it's rare for me to get to
go to a football game you know it son
days and I have to work but it was a
Thursday night game so I was stuck to go
the that stadium was super purple it cut
out I just keep cutting out here I think
Sam does that the County store to exit
since you backed up you're not near that
stadium was surprisingly purple that
Stadium was purple as [ __ ] two-thirds
dragons fans all Viking fans like black
cake Audi's black eggs like these
blacker than that way blacker than that
tickets you can just get tickets
we haven't supported our hometown team
yet well dude it's a man I mean they
were like stadium it was third down for
the Rams offense normally a stadium
would be very quiet for that yeah that's
gold chant where they all do the
clapping thing literally 45,000 people
doing that when the Rams are third down
every game for the Rams and every game
for the Chargers is a road game yeah
it's a stated that USC fills up Oh
coughs names are always bigger I mean
you know like the biggest college names
are bigger than pro stadiums not at all
a USC doesn't sell out that stadium
quite often the only time that they've
actually really sold it out was when
Pete Carroll's team was like the number
one team in the nation that's the only
time they don't sell that out loud it's
93 thousand yeah that's a huge so
they're wired Rams fans outnumbering the
[ __ ] Vikings why co-signing the
Cowboys or the Giants or something
that's a good point we were shocked huge
we were all shocked when like just
walking into the stadium like how many
purple jerseys we were passing and all
of the chants and all the cheers that
they were all doing that stadium is
garbage though it's really garbage yeah
it's in Venus forever to get in it takes
forever to get it it's all hi old stairs
and like how much how much was the
parking around the stadium Oh $150
thousand Mose
expensive blacks 152 Park 152 Park we
ended up parking behind a Mexicans house
forty bucks they charged it was great
long it was great they gave us a grill
yep yeah like 40 bucks is a great deal
it was it was a it was a great deal and
we were like literally like it was
tented where we were at we they just let
us set our grill up in their [ __ ]
yard like we just probably just
basically had a party in their yard
yeah we just made hot dogs for our kids
and [ __ ] like a and then let the kids
have dogs that they want it hey Ari will
you be playing at our Brody Stevens
Festival sports I don't know what is
that it's it's not a great podcast where
you do play the baseball card game ha ha
that's how you play the baseball card
game that's the game yeah I think I mean
as Bazza rams
here's a weird thing right ah we were
talking about it
the Chargers actually had a bigger TV
rating now you were saying it's because
of who they were playing but they got
the Chargers got a bigger TV ratings
than the Rams did on that night Thursday
night game that there's a night game
yeah Thursday night game because it was
a big Thursday I gave my local like when
they played Sunday I think they odd true
give me a week week we can happen yeah
well that you said it was at Chiefs game
which was week one right no no I think
it was week two
all right we'll just wait as he crunches
numbers you have it anyway with what to
what point is that we're gonna do a new
thing called they played the Chiefs week
one September 9 that was one you said it
was because the rest of the games are
the games they were bills Rams Niners
that's all they played Chiefs bills Rams
Niner so it had to be I should be cheese
wasn't the bills that's for sure
the best team in the NFL so yeah last
night but the Rams are the best they're
way better I don't and they wouldn't I
would use the word way better by better
I would because the Rams defense is
[ __ ] way better yeah yeah but I'm
saying there was way in football the
only one
undefeated team no that's not true
Kansas City's on fusion oh really
yeah yeah
okay you know I look that game last
night was great that was a great game it
was no defense and I mean Denver does
Denver Denver has a good pass rush their
secondaries not so great but I'll I was
[ __ ] that guy snapped that ball that
[ __ ] that big whatever game there were
several robbery calls how do you miss
delay of game now that should add you
just have a good one guy who's back over
the shoulder of the quarterback looking
over his shoulder at the play clock it's
so dumb should be like basketball it's
basketball back I know you guys are you
think I'm crazy
that happened Raiders ran Jeff Goff
obviously got the ball out of the
decline
Jeff Goff yes yes Jerry golf here we go
Tarragona the ball after and at that
point was when they just went down a
long long that next that play
you got a completion still haven't and
then it just went to [ __ ] after that
yeah the rough sock man can we all agree
on that like [ __ ] refs gave you I mean
I'm not seeing the Steven talk [ __ ] they
gave the Raiders that game [ __ ] y'all
take it take your word - I take it but I
mean that's if you're the Browns that's
so I mean that's a defensive touchdown
oh boy they like sack fumble now I I
would blew the play dad because you can
touch the quarterback and now he's now
they can take it that's a four easily
strip sack in a touchdown
take it as a ten point game I'll take it
I understand you'll take it yeah but you
understand that the refs are costing
people game you understand I will take
the revs I think I've heard that you
don't give a flying [ __ ] whether it's
fair or not that's a very unique trait
of yours that you don't care how you get
it whether it's robbery Ally yeah yeah
finally Jason understand and Sam will
take it I'll take it I'll make that
paper [ __ ] him yeah okay let okay
somebody really I it was like I don't
even know
maybe it was a meme or it was like some
sort of something because to Packer fans
a girlfriend and a boyfriend and this
guy is like she goes Heidi and then it
goes to tackle her he picks her up like
a little baby and gently sets her down
and then tiptoes away and they're like
this is what a sack is gonna look like
now it's so bad dude aw it's so bad it's
ruining the game somebody push them oh
look who's here
and it's always when its third and 11 do
you get one of these horrible 15 yarders
ah we hate to stop it joining us live
from the but sounds like a bathhouse I'm
a bad day bathhouse in Cleveland uh our
good friend Chad sumac Chad
[ __ ] you triply hey hey first of all
Chad don't come in that hot all right
you're in a gay bathhouse doesn't give
you the right to defend yourself face
yeah
first of all Chad we would like to find
out what kind of apology you want to
make to the fight nanny for calling her
an [ __ ] on Twitter real quick make
the apology make the apology well isn't
the show about controversy I was trying
to drum up controversy now that Sam's
other forecast yeah that's yeah yes Ryan
get along here doesn't always work it's
not working today at all this one's
called this episode should be called
wrong hole okay because nothing seems to
be working out Chad why'd you call the
fight nany an [ __ ] why I was just
trying to drum up business you know if I
want people to listen okay that makes
you accept that okay you're lucky she's
not taken because Chad yes we thought
you were mad at her because she said
that every time she saw you you were
drunk and then you got really angry and
then we kind of broke down every time
she saw you and you were in fact drunk
thoughts thoughts reacts well the good
news is I'm doing silver October from
afar what does that mean I mean from
afar are you doing silver October yes
I'm doing cock-blocked over cock-blocked
over anybody trying to get any [ __ ]
around me I absolutely just kick over
there saying
I feel like you do that anyway at or
like people like to do that then they go
up and like ruin each other's game yeah
Chad let's talk about the most Chad
thing that's ever happened the most Chad
sumac thing in the history of time and
that is yeah you putting out a tweet
celebrating your big win with the Browns
over the Raiders talking about the big
fifty bucks you're gonna get I just
gotta take us through the whole like
next kind of like twenty minutes of your
life that game was over and I just
walked out I was like it's done I did it
was gonna get rigged like it was yeah we
were just talking about that but you
know what Sam we'll take it are your
team still winning half the first half
I'd rather take the first half so Chad
so you put it out you're bragging and
you know the first couple tweets hey hey
okay cool
the first couple tweets that came out
were like hey Chad the game's not over
yet you know what were you thinking when
you saw those tweets you're like gods in
the bag yeah I was in the bag man I mean
you got to look at it this way
straighter Tommy naturally televised
games do they have this either
I don't know matters Raiders probably a
lot we're big brands they don't want
them to be Owen for they want them to
win more people like the Raiders the
game was completely rigged Sam will not
get into that because he does not
believe in conspiracies thank you I
think that's an ad he'll take it I'll
take a Chad did you delete that tweet
Chad you delete that tweet yeah what are
you doing you're an idiot
okay well luckily I screenshot it so let
me read it real quick let me real this
is my favorite thing here it goes Chad
sumac everybody good news
exclamation point Sam Tripoli owes me
$50 after brown
not only am i killing arts fantasy news
I'm killing it on individual bats amis
falling bar this is not good for him i I
tweet back PayPal me [ __ ]
good times dude Chad so so you tweet
this you sabotage me Baker Mayfield you
basically ruin his chance of being the
first rookie quarterback to start his
first game and win it so you ruined that
and then what happens after that when
you find out you lost a bet what you do
well Sam you don't know this and I'm
about to break off an exclusive do you
remember yesterday when I told you I
punched the wall on my hand was hurting
yeah well it turns out my hands broken
now I the most ed sumach thing in the
world everybody Chad sumac just ramped
it up you will never eat more Chad than
that everybody that you will never be
more Chad zoom and zoom och then
tweeting about winning a bat losing the
bat and then punching the wall out of
anger
cuz life is just not worked out and then
busting your hand which is gonna ruin
your act because your whole act is it's
just you doing [ __ ] physical comedy
using your hands making funny [ __ ]
gestures and now you can't even do that
you're kind of petering out by the way
does anyone ever think that that those
those are people doing sign language at
a concert is the dumbest thing I was so
stupid yeah and like is anybody actually
on this thing you're watching that baby
can't hear the music so why are they at
a concert they should all be killed
well well that means one deaf person
went in like sued and was like this is
unfair and now everyone's time it's like
yeah they really like their haircuts I
mean what can you like if you're a deaf
person about a band like so maybe we can
dunk from half-court saw them on the
radio
maybe you're dating like a real person
that can hear and it like deserves to be
alive you know person and then so like
you're going with them to just like hold
their beers or something I don't know I
swear to God I believe they
I'll be executed well dude you know that
one that does those like Eminem concerts
oh yeah I hate that oh god I hate that
she's like here's what I know for
certain there's no deaf people listening
to us right now
we should get a deaf person in here sign
language person in here Jack can you do
some sign language for us oh yeah you
know they say people are deaf and blind
now though that really aren't like oh
I'm legally blind yeah
which these people can see like some
people legally blind they have a
driver's license aren't you legally boy
are you legally [ __ ] illegally blind
these glasses are off you can't see like
across the table take your glasses off
really yeah
what what are you eating in thrill house
they're the same I'm just very near Ryan
O'Neal's prescription which is why I'm
so surprising to have contacts in for
the [ __ ] fight yeah it was also
legally blind yeah what are you eating a
mirror salmon patty
snoring salmon and he's packing for
something that's really good that smoked
salmon oh that's really good no it's
good man
hey Chad Oh were you gonna be this week
I forgot yeah Chad we forgot you were
there
how's the how's the improv of Capri all
week
oh [ __ ] entertaining black people how's
your fantasy team Chad they want to get
right go to green wat I can't believe
you're three in one and you know who's
imperfect yeah I do knows first you [ __ ]
yeah I'm in first in both leagues I'm in
yeah unlike you I'm gonna pay the bet
I'm gonna pay you the bat what does that
mean yeah besides me what do you like
Dinah Shore three and one what you're in
three and one incoming storm yeah Sam
yeah Josh Martin really put it on me but
I won him punch her yeah I'm too into in
part because Sammy Watkins car how crazy
is that we're like oh yeah we're all
like aw you're [ __ ] and then BOOM I
heard it Sammy Watkins is no longer play
I'm like oh
oh I would say this about Sammy Watkins
in that for a team where he should be
lighting it up I don't think he scored
five points once this in fantasy one
time Sammy was I'm seven I'm like even
if he played him like he's is a bust for
when he came out of the league they felt
he was gonna be this [ __ ] murder and
he's I he has had two 13 13 and 0 to 13
13s here ok yeah so he had a potential
hey Chad we're playing each other this
week by the way so Chad start all your
kickers like Sammy Watkins has the
talent and the skill set but he doesn't
have he's never been like an assistant
as important to them yeah yeah yeah hey
hey Chad I sent you a tray for Cam
Newton please check it out Chad don't do
it I'll take a look no I think it's fair
it's good go over the league let's look
at the league give us give us the ahh
standing so we could find out coming in
in first place finger blaster Sam
Tripoli undefeated for a know the only
undefeated team look at that the
opposite of his actual foe best thing is
like whenever it's like a 10 team league
whatever like no you fight a 14 team
league and you always do well in it yeah
every time we've had a 14 team league
you've done good yeah but I got a 14
team league I'm winning and I got a
[ __ ] ten-team League and I'm winning
2nd place is a team go [ __ ] yourself I
don't know they don't have their real
name that's uh that is era Coligny oh ok
alright I'm in 3rd place
Oh remember you were ranked highest by
ESPN I said you're the best I'm gonna I
think I do have the best name you said
what's your what's your move though
what's your team name Chad the Cleveland
spagett they're there in fourth place
uh-huh why would you say the name graves
you live in that area yeah I don't want
to just a line out my door you know the
guy who said that Sports Show Cleveland
[ __ ] grits and gravy that's big t
Dobbs a fantasy expert he's in fifth
who's in laughs alcoholics are six
that's dude hey won two in a row Josh
Martin seven Saskatchewan scapegoats
just beat Josh Martin Binkley the guy
who told his kid about Santa Steve
Rannazzisi by the way he's got the
second most points he's he was almost
iron at the game yeah raging at the game
about our league yeah he was really
excited [ __ ] around in work and then
when Cooper Cup scored that big
touchdown he's like I told you [ __ ]
around anymore Johnny [ __ ] exact way
in the other end of our I'll just
screaming at me and I was a Steve at
that classic Steven is easy where the 1i
just starts to drift it a little bit
drunk
well he's like no he wasn't drunk he was
just worried about the fantasy he was
the best he was drunk and he when he
kind of talks you but you know he's
looking about two feet behind you but he
stopped me oh hey I'll fight anybody I
mean I'll fight triple I know I've
killed triple it I'm like you say you'll
fight me yeah yeah Oh Ari you said you
want to do the Fight League huh what a
great way to bring that up talk about it
Ari Ari wants to do a comic Fight League
chat who do you want fight how much you
weigh Chad 250 280 200 you like to fight
you can fight anybody who'd you fight
chad cuz i know there's a lot of people
you wanna fight
Chris Milhouse okay oh man I think you
should fight Milhouse and Hinchcliffe at
the same time who you gonna fight dude
right Candice it's a fight I want Ari
who you gonna fight you Sam
it's got it yeah let's make your let's
make your list short just mention the
two people you don't want to find I want
to fight you I want I want Jon Jones or
take Fletcher and I will accept nothing
already broken your ribs
I want Rogan and Shop Rogan named I'm
Rogan
up smoking shop at the same time hey um
so what are some good fight matchup Chad
versus Jamar neighbors what are you guys
thinking that tomorrow neighbor should
be in the gym so crazy
I'd like to see Chad fight Jamar
neighbors Freddie
ghetto vs. [ __ ] hood ghetto country
Chad sumac that'd be a great fight I'd
like to see that one comic but one-armed
fight re that's a girl right yeah so
okay we're making we just go on a weak
side I can't see going to a strong side
on that it's just rude did that's just
real um hear about it Chad with the NBA
season starting what is your feelings on
ah
the Cavs you're gonna hang up on me no
I'm not even near it he's telling we're
gonna be fine I think it's gonna be good
my prediction is Chad you make the
playoffs I got him yeah he didn't hang
up on you I did yeah I think that I
think the Cavs make the playoffs and I
think they'll put [ __ ] Joe pray knows
ass hey hey re uh
Cowboys just look better no they really
don't their piece of [ __ ] Ezekiel
Elliott finally at least they're giving
him the ball you don't have chaos
tonight that's the only thing that
getting the ball give me the ball which
is weird because like dak is not the guy
no you're not even in that game where
you played well he's still not like
lights out it was just like a good game
I I don't think they strike anybody no
targets no it's just like I'm regretted
a couple of those were not on him like
he had a touchdown pass I think all
three of our football teams are done
great draw I think Johnny might have the
best football team in the room yes I do
think and we signed Eric Reed get some
why me do
with a sign Gordon yeah I don't know why
they wouldn't do it either I don't think
they need a receipt or even Desmond why
not bring des back he knows his system
yeah bring him back eventually the like
the blood is too bad
did you see LEL you had 88 receiving
yards 150 rushing yards good gay weird
when the team knows they have this
weekend weakness and he just never
seemed to address it you know it's like
how long is Green Bay had a bad line
yeah how long is Pittsburgh had a bad
line they've had a bad life forever so
what do you guys you guys think Earl
Thomas getting hurt changes anything for
levy on bail no no no I mean do you
think I mean it kind of Oh legitimizes
his point yeah flipping off Seattle was
great it was the best and Ben like you
guys drop Seattle cuz he didn't wanna
come back soon enough they made it
because he's like I don't want to have
to come back and play on a shitty
contract but he was losing so much money
that he came back and played basically
without the contract that he wanted hurt
himself now he's done for the year and
now he's just [ __ ] seems like I'm not
gonna get it to the contract now I can't
now I can't get another [ __ ] contract
right and you [ __ ] me so [ __ ] you I
don't know I it was a interesting thing
to see him do and going back going by
all of the Cardinals and they're all
hitting him and being like sorry buddy
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
and then he looks across at his own team
I think it was probably white one guy do
you know it wasn't like it was like her
then wasn't like the ball Boyer's I've
heard anything
[ __ ] you ball boy I haven't heard
anything that he got damn it this
[ __ ] thing oh do you hear it yeah I
do the UH has he said anything about
that today like cuz I'm sure people are
gonna ask him who are you flipping off
like it went beyond viral I mean even
like by the time that game was over out
you had already seen it fifty [ __ ]
times beyond viral it was her oh it went
viral on the
Internet and it was at every commercial
break every television show every sports
show everything on TV you saw up 50
times on TV and memes and you know on
the internet everything era what are you
doing
Aaron what are you my favorite thing
about Aaron he's trying to be sneaky
like we don't see his we could have
stayed professional and just not
acknowledged it okay does that yeah
thanks that was great like that I don't
know why how'd you do people would like
a week talking right again I'm three and
one
I'm dream one as well let's get into our
locks of the week okay
that's up here let's get into our lock
oh wow
Tennessee Buffalo Tennessee's favored
about three and a half a [ __ ] game to
see a buffalo garbage game Roberts game
I think it's a garbage game your lock of
the week is Raiders first half I know
let's see let's see you guys are at
Pittsburgh favored by three Pittsburgh
favored by three oh I take the over on I
take the over on that because Falcons
438 and lose every week Denver versus
who Colts oh yeah dude if you were the
Colts buddy viewer the cult yeah would
you go after Bell if I was a cult I
would cut every black person on my team
and just go the all-white Indianapolis
Colts white power
there it is that's what I would do
that's gonna haunt us um you're
especially racist yeah yeah special your
spell cycle after bell yeah I don't
think he would want to play there where
he wants out what three Wow I suck I
know they're often okay probably top ten
in the NFL our defense is just pure
garbage and the rate of greater saw yeah
but will you suck to our defense socks
our defense sucks we're top five in
yards bro in offense
yeah offensive yards
my lock of the week all over seven
wasn't shut up it's time for our ease
your fears bet the S I bet the aside for
all your betting needs that's where I go
to bet D as I use the promo code punch
25 and get that 25 da da da da cop get
it and you can make you use all your
fears
cold hard lock in the week re what is
your bet deicide cold hard lock of the
week
cold hard lock of the week it is the
rams at the seahawks the line is the
rams are giving up seven and a half
points I am oh my god
I say the Seahawks will cover that
spread I'm so sure of it
you can here's my test race you can take
a dump on it
[Laughter]
Johnny's the first time Johnny smiles
away sees a man's nakedness alright
you're saying that the Seahawks will
cover the seven points or the random and
you were take the Seahawks plus seven
wins
Indy's getting ten at New England Kansas
City favored by three at home versus
Jacksonville Denver at the Jets the Jets
are favored by one their Green Bay at
Detroit Green Bay is favored by one and
a half Baltimore Cleveland Cleveland's a
three point dog at home Oh boohoo giant
Baltimore oh that's a rivalry towards
good
Baltimore's good Giants at Carolina
Carolina's favored by seven I might take
Carolina but the Giants give him points
Miami at Cincinnati Cincinnati by six no
Oakland at Cleveland five and a half
Oakland at Cleveland I mean yeah oh
sorry Oakland at the Chargers five and
half Oakland Oakland in LA this weekend
oh really
yeah charges you does it sold out it's
for
it's a charge oh I'm going dude I might
be because it's a Raiders though I'm
gonna go I'm gonna use my seat key cap
Arizona's at San Francisco San
Francisco's favored by four and a half
over the garbage Minnesota no I kind of
like Houston at Dallas at hue thousand
three
I like Houston in that with a
three-point dog's favorite yeah
DeSean watch I'm looking kind of iffy
there right yeah yeah but so is
everything about Dallas and then
Washington is getting six and a half at
New Orleans I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
the other way Ari and I'm gonna say my
lock of the week and you can take a piss
on it I mean your dude his Rams covering
the same spread yeah oh you know I'm
just gonna take that as well so I am
going to I'm gonna give you two cold
hard locks I'm gonna give you a Rams
giving up the point taken given the
poise like in the line as a seven now
okay even better so take the Rams and
take the Raiders in the first half boom
you put those together you got yourself
a little scratch out of line you can do
better on half of them they didn't win
the first half this week well you know
put it back down I'm gonna say they get
back to their winning the first half
ways and second half yeah I do believe
they wouldn't say I'm sorry I think the
Chargers are in trouble we should have
the nanny go against you guys and see
Danny pick a cold hard lock real quick I
feel like I'm worse than Lewis at naming
teams like I can't even name a team
getting four and a half s yeah yeah all
right Seattle's garbage sorry hey that's
how much how bad is that game what
Arizona a Seattle friend oh that's even
worse yeah sure is what a garbage yeah
it looked like it was gonna be
interesting
guys are so excited I feel like you have
to watch it then yeah well don't you
have a bag of bets ons wash that whole
thing just [ __ ] San Francisco fans are
really excited I literally do have to
watch that entire [ __ ] game I do a
little quick we got a couple things
getting to UFC can we talk about it no
it's a podcast let's just sit in silence
we should do a silent podcast once where
we just show each other knows but no one
can hear what we're saying
people would zoom in we have fans that
would do that that would zoom in on like
the use of what are they I'm excited
shut up fine daddy
zip it there's no video there's no video
for it either it's just an audio so we
can't see these how are we gonna do this
for the Nate Diaz hey so just go we're
gonna give you I hear some cuz I'll go
out for that voice Weidman's on that
card two guys it's like a dream card
okay you want me to start the prelims
yeah the main card start let's just do
the main card card to you to ufc's ago
Michelle Waterson and the karate hottie
police hair I like police Harris I just
she's hot I like she's herring yeah
Harry whatever I'm going to go karate
hottie on this one just 15 and 6 and 14
and 7 pretty even who do you got in that
hottie karate hottie just is there like
her name is prettier white-trash
fighting goo cootie got okay okay but if
this is porn you next five girls Derrick
Lewis the black beast versus Alexander
Volkov Drago ah listen here's the
problem the black beast last fight was
so bad no I hope this is more exciting
and I feel like he could easily if he
has a [ __ ] fight could like drop
completely out of the rankings
b.push alike like I think this is that
he's fighting for his relevance right
now
I agree his last fight was so bad I mean
looking like France and they got that
guy hasn't been the same since that dog
ship fight since he lost too steep yeah
he was so boring in that too is like
dying it's it's weird when these guys
think they're invisible invisible you
can't see me can you seeing these videos
or parents convince their kids they're
invisible I used to do that in my little
sister know I used to do it all the time
- yes you would cry and cry yeah I get
my parents to play along we just cry cry
you're like why are you crying so
grabbing moms vibrators you want to tap
her on the head and be like oh you're
such an evil [ __ ] so imma go all with
the other guy what do you mean Alexander
Volkov yeah I'm gonna go Alexander
Volkov I just like the name it sounds
like a bad guy he's not in a black no
black hole about you nanny I don't think
they're close to Louis the one either
okay so we're all on the same team yeah
we're on the same team I'll go Derrick
loose on that this [ __ ] French girl
redeems I think so but his back issues I
don't know I think you're going Derek
Lou I think so yeah all right this guy
oh what's this
horsey versus do any of you he's not at
home
all SP just is like the guy who like all
that guy looks like he should be killing
everybody and then mentally puts himself
somewhere and he gets knocked out yeah
I'll go with OSP on this yeah yeah yeah
it's almost like a gatekeeper kind of
situation with this guy being 9 - no and
I'll be like that's a lot of 9/11 or
whatever the [ __ ] he is it's a little
weird he's guys pants low man cross so
i'ma go always pee - yeah ah Ferguson
versus a good
I think Ferguson on this one I think
Pettis is he's like not gatekeeper now
but he's like yeah he's done do ever
since the drug testing I'll take
Ferguson on this yeah that's what I
think like I think this will be a good
fight
I do think this would be a I think I'd
light I love Ferguson dude like he's got
a weird attitude but he like looks like
a coke dealer he talks like a me wrong
come into your house and I'll bang your
girl what are you thinking that you like
yes let me watch and here we go the big
fight I gotta be honest with you the
hype on this fight is not nearly as big
as I think they thought it would be it's
not like people can't stop talking about
this McGregor doesn't want to do any
promo who's his third loss it isn't a
Dustin Poirier no he lost a long time
ago to awesome Irish guy that's actually
in UFC that was a long time ago then he
lost to not just Emporia no no no ahh I
I'm really amazed at Nate no I know that
and then some um God who's the other one
I don't think it's Poirier no it's not
somebody weird Nate Diaz Dulli Duffy
sorry and then sit Nick off okay yeah
those are way back in the day
yeah 2010 and 2008 were the first which
is back in the day can you believe that
2008 is back in the day back in the day
I think it's partly because he's become
unlikable I'm taking McGregor in this
don't you think he's become I'm saying
that because I can't really go against
him ever that's the thing with him
that's I just want to see him loose well
I'm gonna tell you this the only way
could be wins this thing is by knockout
or tap or like completely on him the
whole time this is it you don't listen
to him down it's gonna be so hard for
him to get a decision versus Connor
because the UFC the Nevada fighting
every
buddy makes more money if Connor has the
belt yeah
this guy doesn't barely talks English
doesn't like cuss words doesn't like
like dude they don't want to hear this
[ __ ] guy like right right
it's they're dying to do they're dying
to get into Russia they're dying to get
into China dying to get an image are
they dying right after you know Nate ds2
then maybe even matter but now it could
be beets and it's almost like oh yeah
that guy's been out of MMA for two years
that's not yeah there's a are not a TED
talk about a like a like a you I look it
up on YouTube but it's uh who's got Tony
Robbins and he's it's the whole hours
Tony Robbins at one of his big [ __ ]
seminar things and the entire hour he's
interviewing Dana White about being a
success and how he changed UFC and how
they almost sold it for ten million
bucks they lose so much money and now
it's a billion-dollar thing and they
just sold it and all this when they
start mentioning the UFC getting into
Russia and China if you watch that look
you can literally smell Dana White's
boner when he starts talking about like
oh god if we get into China he's
literally like what weiming smell like
would you say what was this house Dana
White's billions of dollars right cash
billion not like the austin cheese or
anything like that no it smells like a
nice thick [ __ ] rock-hard purple [ __ ]
like a veiny real smoke show Wow no cuz
already hates black people on this
episode specially when you talk about
black dicks so go your picks go your
picks on it I just said Connor Connor
Ari
Kabhi Kabhi Johnny it's over so you hate
Connor are you room for khabib yeah but
I'm just confused why you guys don't
think his like you think he has
wrestling defense now because here's
what I think I think he definitely does
in a sense of accurate striking accurate
striking
what about when he fought Chad Mendes
like five years ago and that was like
not good who won it's two years since
guys know what I know I mean nobody's
talking about that it's been two years
no I'm with you I'm now Emile marques
all the time and doesn't care about
anything
tiger level might be why what are you
talking about a new comedy finally
you're gonna have to be on coke to fight
you had to flunk a drug test in order to
[ __ ] fight I'm a gold khabib as well
what if you do drugs oh so you have to
test positive for something shiny you're
going to be yeah yeah I think so yeah I
mean it's been two years now I do agree
that two years saying and you're so rich
that you don't give a [ __ ] anymore about
I think he does it was before he was the
wrestler he was always stylistically he
does it does create problems by whose
whole life is that right so here's what
I actually was just I thought about this
that the fact that Connor didn't want to
do a lot of press actually hurts his
chances of getting in to khabib 'he's
head the like if they would have done a
bunch of this stuff he could have been
grilling him getting his head now they
only did one press conference he hasn't
had the time begin to [ __ ] this
dude's head yeah I mean he also threw
the [ __ ] chair a chair I mean you
know he did a for a year he was trying
to get in his head but right before the
fight I think he you know I mean that
was just him being great he it like
could be right Gibbs in his own head
okay so we we got to talk about
something you guys made a little
handshake agreement during the patreon
we were discussing something last night
whoa go on Sam Sann if teeb wants to
also put a hot dog in his ass
cuz you want to sample wave the other
beds but yeah I feel like you felt left
out so I mean there is a sense of
camaraderie that I do like yeah but I
would prefer mine to be a bacon wrap
like for your pasta or something so re
basically the thing is if if he reads
shove a hot dog up his ass we won't have
him do the other bets that's what he
what that training walk and then
shot-caller electrocute which you don't
want to do jerking off on skype well Sam
to Mari was the training won't it was
the Raiders versus foul I mean your team
Falcons versus his the Cowboys that's
what it was yeah who would make the
playoffs okay or some like that and then
Sam was one and then Marissa's one yeah
all right hey uh breaking news Ari on
the way home go get a dress of her you
can do it [ __ ] this afternoon no it has
to be after midnight after midnight TV I
let it all hang out dig wagon it's just
embarrassing but there's no sorry
bringing you re breaking news I'm
excited to hear it and I want to hear it
you're saying he's breaking this job
just said on Joe Rogan khabib wants the
beat connor and retire undefeated that
might be he might retire after this fine
wants to beat Conor Oh retire though oh
wow too crazy somewhat uh he doesn't
have a contractor named like that I mean
it doesn't matter it matters don't want
to be around it anymore maybe he just
realized the UFC has jumped the shark
and gone to [ __ ] or maybe he gets beat
by Conor and still retires so give us a
time to do this this wall this wall real
quick Tran so that leads to two others
uh would you do the hot dog to get out
of two others yeah how about that are we
well no but that's it but I'm saying if
he could if he could ask murders and
murders would agree and then Sam would
agree
would youwould you mean you'd only have
to do the hot dog in a random walk you
wouldn't have to jerk off her shocked
dog bets the worst one yeah it's way
worse dude hot dog up your [ __ ] it's
nothing it's the easiest bet on a table
out of everybody in your argument you
should be like no I don't want a hot dog
they're not gonna give it Danny when you
get ain't no how's it graded do you feel
like do you feel like a real piece of
[ __ ] when you get when Jeff puts it in
your butt beyond and even likes giving
it yeah you didn't see that coming come
on dude just ridiculous bad laugh you
guys are just feeling bad for them okay
yeah it is okay alright no it's it's
easy in the sense that is quick like it
doesn't take a lot of preparation no
yeah I feel like bagger Betts has not
been a thing on I have one too oh you
guys Oh three or four I don't he's dying
to put a hot dog in this ass
and I'm gonna go with the plan again
Santa Monica and do it in LA than
begging for money
alright I'm willing to do it or should I
get here a colonic in my butt and get
rid of all the math yeah like we just
talked about white anal beads before the
show so yeah no I'm loud you're [ __ ]
just Park me what you think you've been
practicing I want to thank much of it
this car smart Ari
so you're saying no deal on any of his
things
yes that's what we're saying because I
just want to get them done can we get
you drumsticks maybe drumsticks would
help deflect another deflection yeah
what am i deflecting it's like we are
doing we're not doing it we're not doing
it and I still may put a hot dog in my
ass yeah sorry yeah
he tortured you about that Lakers Jersey
saying you haven't done it you haven't
done it you haven't done you haven't
done you haven't done it for years he
tortured you did you let him off the
hook took them two years to pay off the
Whitney bed when it's taken this long to
pay off the easiest [ __ ] bed every
five dogs easiest best do it [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] Tebow Oh YouTube
bets are easier than that to pay off you
can't get a USA chant going walking down
the Manhattan
you are the longest bet I am it's a
two-year-old back that's fine it's two
years old do you think we should still
do bag of bugs hold they re you are in
that stop macula somebody else why
should we do it three you're three and a
hot dog a bad [ __ ] beat up [ __ ]
nothing's gonna slip right in there
though no I think it I think we could
actually see a waterfall of blood ari
Ari you said that you had a solution and
that you were gonna stop wiping right
what what happened why have you been
shooting a lot so your move has been
you're just going to [ __ ] and then just
jump right in the shower and that's it
this guy looks like this every day but
it's always like that that's what it's a
shot like a decade that he takes how is
massive about it alright once a day
what's right what's a day for two hours
ari we agreed you probably live the
longest out of all of us yeah I mean
well Johnny because okay dude your ass
is just a waterfall of blood and I look
dude I can't I'm nervous for you bro but
it's a drug addiction he's an alcoholic
but your [ __ ] is in way worse shape
than are the factors right doctor
apparently signed off on it though right
all right it's on you're just you got a
[ __ ] waterfall coming out of your
both dr. Seuss who's your doctor
needs more what bleeds more month fight
nanny's vagina or Ari Zack had a period
since before I got pregnant thank you so
Ari when still not going still don't
want when you breastfeed it doesn't come
back oh my my breastfeed for the rest of
my just every time like Ari's in this
whole bathroom area you know got [ __ ]
baby wipes in his hand that's what we
need that's where it goes you do use
baby wipes right yes I can't even look
I'll make God look real it looks like
Halloween fake blood the amount of blood
I just look down looking hey Johnny can
we set up the night he's gonna do the
trans walk this way hey Ari when you're
in a hurry do you stuff anything up your
ass like when you had to go out so you
don't stay in your otherwise he makes
tampons you do man you imagine he's like
walking in his like khakis and it's just
like stick imagine the smell of that
thing he's the only man is part of the
free bleeding move my tampons in your
ass resist okay so what are you thinking
about the walk-in why I don't care would
hey Ari would you guys be interested in
doing the begging and the training walk
at the same time no he wouldn't be he's
dumb if he if he cares if you don't
wants to do that cuz then we could film
it in one shot
yeah but here's my errands given us a
wrap up oh he's not done until we have a
stablish show here we've been here since
[ __ ] the beginning of the box
oh you just lost sorry Aaron really not
good buddy not good so once again the
oppressive people who run this network
who forgotten about how hard we work to
get the old studio have told us that we
have to get out of here and now fight
nanny's gonna cry so guys thank you
autistic robot Thank You 70s DJ come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] Dodgers [ __ ] you Aaron
and I will see you guys next week guys
take care bye